citizens of the reject Nation we are here
to watch the Mandalorian episode dose today
of course joined by John John Howard Johnson
ah John is John and this is the John Michael
how was Michael I'm Michael yes he is I Love
Lamp guys follow MJ tesler on Instagram and
Twitter today thank you so much for being
here our Star Wars Aficionado as we call them
around these parts of the rejection expert
I am man you got to work on that a little
bit ladies and gentlemen leave a like for
Michael he used the force to leave a like
subscribe click that notification Bell because
we are obviously covering this weekly and
full length Reaction watch long as we sync
up with your own copy of the Mandalorian available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
thank you to all who have joined so far her
support is astronomical and I'm Michael yes
you are it's not sponsored by them I always
got one in my hand so if you guys want to
get yourself some g-fuel today you know 20
off promo code reject Nation I drink these
religiously it's a part of my religion get
it get it is the way G fuel is a part of my
religion you remove the can from your hand
your exercise
[Laughter]
[Music]
tattooing it's tattooing
shot first trying to push it back out in the
street you heard him pitch right no no no
no no no no no no no drive a hard bargain
Peli Moto let's say two months don't settle
your snout I'll put a rush on it you know
I do have a life big holiday I have big plans
it's never even been to space it's the anniversary
of the Death Star hey tell the job was rodian
left or a life day let's get this thing back
together again quickly before he sees you
put those parts back on the speeder paint
them so they look different here you go
[Music]
where's my guy
he is
you had a leap like a Lerman huh Luke Skywalker
did was that his first word I think he's talking
to me did you hear that he said he simply
no he didn't I'm looking for a replacement
IG memory circuit oh hey Grandpa they haven't
made those for
a while
I bet
so good I think you should buy this beauty
here
I need a Droid that can explore ahead of me
and test the atmosphere make sure it's safe
to breathe you're
could be piloting starfighters across the
Galaxy
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you this
for half the price it's sugar tree is a little
fragile I thought you said it was built for
adventure
[Music] I love the second life of R5 right
now
so with you Pele Moto all right kid you ready
for an adventure
you know what they're celebrating but yeah
happy bunta guys
a mine
same but it was once green and beautiful back
when the songs were written the cosmos it's
Mandalore the Homeworld of our people I've
never been there either I grew up there on
that Moon Concordia wow nice that's kalavala
where we visited Boca Town a Mandalorian has
to understand maps and know their way around
you'll never be lost I love teacher Ninja
Force grade on a curve
this poor R5 Droid
two
wow this is gorgeous breathtaking from the
surface we won't be able to communicate with
anyone out of atmosphere down here we're completely
cut off from the rest of the Galaxy foreign
don't worry nothing bad will come of that
water has been so much build up to going here
finally our five you ready I'm gonna need
you to scout ahead and analyze the atmosphere
[Laughter] [Music]
take an air sample of the ruins below
this R5
don't be a baby [Laughter]
I don't like this we've got a bad feeling
about this
don't disappear yep I'll go get them
damn this is beautiful
don't worry kid I'll be right back hey Miss
Lazarus emotional and physical atmosphere
of this place yeah right [Music]
apparatus sounds like Vader
wow good cousin ballon's down there somewhere
whoa
The Time Machine
come on buddy work with it
nice
damn peace best car weapons they have probably
yeah
[Music] or five oh buddy man was gonna take
his helmet off again I'm sorry oh [__]
well at least I'm here to get you back to
the ship
[Music] no he's so happy
the charts were wrong huh the atmosphere is
breathable what else were they lying about
oh Katan was right Mandalore is not cursed
entire religion I should call her and apologize
too quiet
that's the Civic Center oh good and then the
Performing Arts Plaza is just down there
awesome
I guess the city was domed once upon a time
I love this episode yeah this is so cool so
tense right now sci-fi dread
this is so freaking cool Baboo freaking cool
uh we go we're gonna go back there
another extinct but I feel like we might see
a mythosaur that's what I was thinking too
that's the balrog
what are those you know what those are I don't
recognize them they're not dank ferricks dankest
ferrets out here
how many more down there
whoa oh what what is this uh that's one of
those Purge droids
oh wait no is that something different I don't
know oh damn there's a total I in there it's
a Star Wars Dalek
huh it looks like a bug
oh that feels like a person's in there
this little Krang
what the hell what
oh God I don't like this it's like an intelligent
xenomorph yeah
Android organic Android thing
ugh
what the hell is that it kind of reminds me
of in the unknown regions there's a species
called the grisk that is like the secret big
bad in the Beyond maybe they're after best
car in the unknown regions
do
you think grogu
come on buddy whoa
[Music]
whoa whoa dude
ambulance movie yeah it's gonna be grogu and
a bunch of other little way more spikes it's
like Mario
I want this to be a ride yeah
damn who directed this episode
[Laughter]
my man come on R5 [Music]
oh and he knew where the planet was
oh my God Boca tanzanus show up to help
yo Majesty you've been sitting on this chair
for six months an unscheduled visitor
thank you why does anyone respect my schedule
these trailer shots I want to be left alone
what happened to him help a spoke at 10 your
only hope download the Astromech find out
where they were you know where they
were
those mandalorians that I make a ship
I way prefer this because I feel like an earlier
season Boca town would have just randomly
been there Save the Day
ah I got a little smile on your face happy
to be home home sweet home
yeah wow there's the Dome
get pelimoto in here
it didn't always look like this yeah I heard
what face is that even there's a lot of unprocessed
trauma right there it's a woman's face you
judgmental prayer okay okay kid I'm gonna
need you to guide me to him can you do that
this is the parrot but I didn't know I needed
ask your chance to take the dark saver of
Lucas what's the worst that happens our planet
gets genocided again
I mean if you've withstood one genocide
textures on everything yeah I love the glassing
of a planet that obsidian look I love her
hips look at that Star Wars hourglass God
[Music] my family ruled it all [Music]
says Goku controlling that now
you can eat one I know that you're frightened
but I need you to guide me to him man up
I heard you take it back nice [Laughter] part
of me hopes Kroger never learns to actually
speak I feel like we're gonna start seeing
some words here and there I knew quite a few
Jedi you know there was a time we actually
got along quite well fought side by side [Music]
nope
oh you're good
nicely done
oh man
he is nice
did you think your dad was the only Mandalorian
those are alamites and we were their next
meal if they survived I wonder what else might
have to
go
drain you of your human oil
is that a spit it could be what are they pumping
out
oh it affects best car
oh there it is [Music]
oh
oh nice oh look how comfortable yeah man that's
awesome
dad can you hear me yes
you gotta be flipping kidding oh no it's gonna
get the bigger body behind you yeah
oh my God she's so good with it oh she had
it for a while yeah
take that module and destroy it
give me back my dark saber
you can have my blood what happened I saved
your life gave you some penicillin you were
right Mandalore is not cursed was I nothing
to cling to but ashes what is this you've
never eaten POG soup no can you appreciate
the irony
you should rest I'll get you back to my ship
soon enough I must continue to the minds of
Mandalore so that I may be redeemed I honestly
think that it's adorable that you actually
believe these children's stories without the
Creed what are we our people are scattered
like stars in the galaxy the Creed is how
we survived I can't go with you until I fulfill
my obligation I will take you wow we can bathe
together don't thank me until you see them
Living Waters
it's gonna be an Ayahuasca trip I wonder if
there's anybody down there the Empire set
out to punish us to wipe away our memory it
must pain you to see it like this after witnessing
its beauty that's understaffing your own kind
fight one another time and time again killing
each other for reasons too confusing to explain
it made us weak huh maybe you shouldn't have
joined Death Watch then problem with all these
different sects of your religion can't come
to an agreement I was part of the royal family
the rituals were all just theater for our
subjects they loved watching the princess
recite the Mandalorian tenants as her father
looked on proudly your father sounds like
an interesting man he died defending Mandalore
this is the way [Music] we're gonna bring
up your dead sister The Living Waters I want
you to get the full tour according to ancient
folklore the mines were once a mythical lair
yep it is from these legends that the skull
Signet was adopted and became the symbol of
our planet oh man this is it
take it all off but the helmet yes hey you
might get your wish
I swear on my name oh and the words of the
Creed shall be forever forged in my heart
oh no
[Music] is it really
oh wow he's definitely bathing
wow what a great shot great shot yeah James
Cameron did this episode
what the [__] his armor was just so heavy
that's twice she's had to save him
yeah uh man oh man we're not ready POV yeah
oh [__] my God no way oh that is insane
a tease at the scale yeah
oh wow damn it who's Rachel Morrison I don't
know give her a raise seriously have we seen
her director credit before I don't know that
was great wow yeah that was terrific love
the mood I didn't think we would get that
I mean I thought it earlier but for some reason
in the moment I was like maybe not yeah sure
enough given up will that uh that was a great
episode that was a really really great episode
God continues to subvert expectation I love
that they credit the somebody pointed that
out they credit the stunt actors who actually
do Mando now oh good yeah it's those last
two names there who cares they're not Pedro
Pascal's voice he's a busy guy it's all about
those few minutes Pedro spends in the booth
man yeah that was that was phenomenally executed
it was it was so well done yeah I I loved
the the direction they're going with Boca
tan because I can't quite tell where it is
I still I don't think it's what we think uh
but what do you mean I don't think that Bo
could now anything you think is going to be
wrong that's not the thought you were thinking
I have several thoughts what am I wrong about
I don't think Bo's gonna be the villain no
no no nor do I I think they're going to have
something where there will be it's going to
be like a cobra Kai situation is what I think
is going to go down John Katan Crees is coming
where nowhere they they are going to have
a difference of ideologies and they will butt
heads but they have to reunite men but eventually
yeah they are gonna see that they are the
thing that will bring Unity to it so did his
evil thing and Bo katana's Miyagi dose yeah
or one or the flipping around doesn't matter
which one but yeah the one of the two that's
what I think that's where they're headed with
it where it seems like they could be on the
brink of like fighting amongst each other
but they're going to realize that ultimately
that's not the key to a greater threat uh
no I I completely agree I mean uh I I appreciated
the the subtle Nuance of of lore um subtle
there's a lot well I mean it was when it comes
to Mandalorian Lord you could just well they
didn't put on a 40-minute YouTube that's what
I'm saying uh I thought it was it was really
casually well done but like the way that Beau
looked at Din when he was in the water was
just like I respect your commitment and tenacity
but also there might be something to this
this is a beautiful moment yeah I mean she
washed away judgment in that moment and I
I think began to see a future that has otherwise
the idea of a future for Mandalore felt extinct
for her and I think in Den she sees a future
um and I I I'm really really excited I I just
keep wondering have we not even met our big
bad yet um I'm not sure because what's cool
about these two episodes together I kind of
feel like they could have they're tonally
in pace so different and I get why they're
two separate episodes but they could have
prepared them both on the same day yeah glad
they didn't because that would have been a
lot of editing for me thank you Disney glad
they did it but did it just for granted when
they do that [__] I'm like Jesus Christ
it's gonna be a long long night um but um
what's what's different already structurally
is it doesn't feel like mission of the week
that eventually becomes tethered together
uh but in the last few episodes like how the
first two seasons were like this is immediately
after the first episode and it's it feels
very serial and even where this ends off it
feels very much like this whole all the episodes
are going to be way more connected and very
focused yeah exactly where I really loved
the structure of of the first two seasons
I love the the red because it's like the missions
are well Justified like well I need to survive
so I need to take on some missions and then
how they come together I think it's really
cool but to see these two back to back uh
it does put it in a different lens for how
this can progress and I really just want to
say this I think this is Katie sackhoff's
best work she's done thus far uh as being
live action Boca tan it's a it's a tough character
to adapt to live action um it was so it was
I mean Beau is such a uh in in Clone Wars
I'm trying to say what I know you're thinking
not what I'm thinking I'm I'm saying that
she's a complicated character and has been
from the first time that we saw her um I mean
first time we met Beau in Clone Wars she was
on the wrong side yeah um and I think has
always been a very impulsive quick to react
character uh and I appreciate that going back
to Mandalore facing her mistakes we're seeing
just a really interesting nuanced character
um that is is making for just like great storytelling
yeah are you no no not at all do you think
but what if uh it's not possible being on
the reject there's definitely definitely reaching
all right I mean I I feel like they were indicating
to us throughout this episode that there are
other survivors of a Mandalorian background
who may have survived and may still be on
Mandalore um do you think that's a possibility
do you think there's definitely yeah I mean
that was the whole point of what bocatan was
saying with like what else could have survived
and you do see that there's these other there
are there are qualities about this that felt
like the most obvious one to note is you have
some like aliens uh but also this did have
like when you when you call them like the
second time warlocks was like that's exactly
what I was thinking too was very much in like
an H.G Wells type of situation yeah if you
guys haven't seen the time machine watch The
Guy Pierce one that's a superior version that's
the version Orlando Jones Jeremy Irons boy
that's the one to go with uh but no it did
it did resonate in that regard uh because
you know like there is this Gap in time that
we just haven't seen of what happened here
so even though it's not a time travel episode
we have jumped forward with if you if you
take the time with clone wars and Rebels uh
anything to do with Mandalore that's not only
you just skip ahead like oh it's all gone
now it's all it's all destroyed it's the ruins
so there is a sense of of like a time travel
quality to it only because of the fact that
there is this chunk that we're missing that
eventually Kathleen Kennedy's gonna be like
produce that show we got to see it now we
got to fill in all the gaps I mean all of
it needs to be visuals Nothing To The Head
yeah if there's a millisecond that is unaccounted
for in Canon yeah make it a show then making
a shower movie well I think that's what's
kind of neat um like who's gonna play Young
that's a great question
no I mean I I do agree that we will see that
um either in the form of flashbacks or in
uh future animated property yeah it's gonna
be expensive um uh no yeah I think animation
is probably the the right move for that um
no I mean that that period between Rebels
and now like yeah things really hit the fan
on Mandalore um I'm I'm really interested
to see if
these was ever left you know yeah are they
okay what's what's going what's going on that
we haven't seen them or heard from them or
or do they even know the war is over like
I wonder if uh uh it's gonna be like like
the Japanese World War II soldiers that like
in the 1970s they were like still trying to
catch some of the guys on the island who didn't
believe that they surrendered um which would
be really cool to see like um Japanese like
fenrao Fen Rao from uh Rebels who was one
of the Mandalorian protectors who was you
know friends with Beau uh I just think it'd
be really cool to see what happens to the
mandalorians who still think the fight's going
on uh and I feel like that could be an interesting
Star Wars loves to pull from World War II
or yeah so I mean yeah there's a lot of interesting
aspects this can go down but I I do want to
just appreciate like what the episode in and
of itself did because this was more because
remember last last week that Premiere episode
of saying that this feels like the most light-hearted
and hopeful mandalorians ever been and start
off that way when I'm so used to be kind of
being darker yeah and then the second episode
is this is more the Mandalorian that I know
and love because I really like the last episode
uh a lot but this was this is more my cup
of tea when it comes to the Mandalorian and
it was paced so well it was filled with a
lot of tension and it had life day I know
John Favre really loves that does he does
I don't know why he loves you so much because
the holiday special is the greatest Star Wars
content that was ever created is that the
same R5 Droid from I think a new hope it's
just been kicking around this long yeah I
mean and to think how different that's the
what if series I want to watch what if R5
was picked instead of R2 uh we would have
had a whole other Series yeah sure it would
never have been as popular yeah it would have
just been Luke going to Tachi station to pick
up some power converters yeah
but what does he do with them is the question
but what'd you think of the set design John
I love the set design I thought this did really
nicely to I've always thought the Mandalorian
has looked really good in the way it realizes
things but you know we live in a world now
where the volume especially is just a much
more noticeable thing and everybody is a little
more aware that that happens and here I I
found myself having the sort of the thought
you want to have where you're like this doesn't
look like the volume you know this looks really
tangible tangible yeah and I love just yeah
getting to know these ruins and like kind
of like you said like it has all that stuff
that you love from the Mandalorian but this
also kind of felt like it did progress the
tone the style because you are just sort of
drinking in the air all of the air of you
know this this worn down decimated space and
uh I loved the discovery of that the fun that
led to you get these creatures and things
like that and and even though there are a
lot of desolate and rendered planets that
we visit in a show like this this felt like
a a place with even just seeing it here intimately
in this one episode it already has this this
care it feels like a character unto itself
yeah there's an architectural Wonder still
yeah well I think that's one of my favorite
parts of like the Nuance of Mandalorian culture
and lore is that like they're not just Epic
Warriors they're also artists like they're
also Architects like Sabine wren's like when
he's introduced you know you're expecting
to see this like great Mandalorian warrior
and it turns out he's just like an art nerd
and I I think exploring that's kind of what
like the armor represents that too I mean
everything everything about them is very there
is a a a traditional Warrior artistic style
to them yeah I mean I I think that's why they
made such wonderful Rivals to the the Jedi
um because it mirrors that kind of the The
Art of War and culture and like that Samurai
feeling of you know these different Clans
each have these these symbols that represent
them and and this ideology is ancient um and
you know I think it's neat that what was Star
Wars Legends is slowly becoming like and and
I love even for example when they introduced
the idea of the mythosaur and kind of like
gave us a little contextual background I love
that the mandalorians understanding of what
happened is just as like questionable as our
understanding of what happened because it's
Legends for us too yeah um and it's history
through multiple lenses and perspectives yeah
well and I think it's kind of neat uh it makes
the characters uh a little bit like us well
you know they used to ride them at the source
too Conquest so I'm thinking that if they
if they can somehow pull that mythosar out
and they could use it to fight whatever big
Baddie and not just big Baddie but think of
the symbol of yeah yeah but I'm talking because
the dark savior absolutely because canonically
speaking the helmet of Mandalore was the symbol
and then the dark saber was stolen by Clan
V's love from the Jedi Temple and then that
became the symbol and now the dark saber has
like a lot of just bad vibes around it like
it's the sword that killed like energy around
me yes it's kind of weird that the dark Sabers
they have dark energy but uh I feel like it
would be really interesting to to have you
know as you create the legend of this new
Mandalore and this new leader who I really
feel didn't yarn is like the especially the
fact that they did make you know Canon and
clear that he is from the Mandalore system
um I thought that was really like coming from
Concordia uh as where he was from I thought
was a really nice like oh great he's like
actually Mandalorian and not like a foundling
from somewhere totally random um it's not
a randolorian yeah a random Lori well I mean
he still could have been the foundling who
was raised there
well well no no no you have me doubting myself
he was really young I spent a lot of time
in therapy to get over as much doubt in you
would mind uh no yeah because of mandalorians
like a nationality it's not a race it's kind
of like being Jewish religion act like being
Jewish yeah no that's exactly speaking as
the Jew in the group um that's exactly what
it is it's both a race of people but well
the interesting thing is the ancient mandalorians
if we're going by like Legends if there was
a race that was separate of humans and humans
ended up becoming the majority but Mandalorian
as a culture was something that was slowly
adapted yeah um so the Mandalorian race is
as as an actual race went extinct and if you
believe in Legends which I do they come from
Coruscant
um now you don't believe in Legends Greg that's
something yeah well it's a tall tale Mike
uh well you know uh yeah I'm I'm just really
really excited to figure out what is the unifying
event that will bring the mandalorians back
together um and we know you know uh that at
least by the time of the sequel Trilogy that
mandalorians are still around in the galaxy
because they were one of the flags at Maz
kanata's Palace yeah I remember that you don't
remember that's the only thing I remember
I I remember watching the trailer on the real
rejects pausing and being like that's the
Mandalorian flag sure hope I get to talk about
that one day on the real rejects I mean it
was just like you were here in the room for
a second yeah crazy uh no I don't remember
any of that uh
yeah I I know you don't love me getting too
excited about the other Star Wars shows um
because you want to focus on the present and
be here in this show um but I do really love
the idea I hate it I know you hate it but
I do really love this idea of you know uh
the the person who gave bocaton the dark saber
Sabine Wren there's a character from Rebels
um is like definitively going to be a big
part of the Ahsoka series which will it sounds
The Soca series sounds like Rebels continued
live action what should a Time Jumper which
I feel like will have a uh would be really
useful for them to have an army of mandalorians
at their side oh definitely no so there's
the the rebel the Soco show I just view as
live action Rebels I'm like great that's what
it sounds like to me whatever I hear about
oh that sounds like every character from Rebels
is returning basically I've sold sold uh yeah
I mean I know thrawn had a my favorite Star
Wars characters loved Mandalorian culture
uh and found it really really fascinating
so yeah I'm just excited to see how the dots
connect um and the tone of this like this
is obviously so different from Andor and I
feel like that was a big complaint that I
saw from the last episode is that and or kind
of changed the game of what we expected of
Star Wars content um but like Anders this
like great World War II spy Thriller this
is like Lord of the Rings of yeah sure and
it's interesting like existing within the
same universe but having these like wildly
different genres that exist within that you
know franchise well I feel like that's something
that could be happening you know we'll see
as the season unfolds but I I don't expect
this show to become and or have that level
of concern with what its allegory is doing
necessarily but I do feel like especially
seeing this season take a shape that feels
a little more directly serial as you pointed
out uh could lend itself and they're also
like they're back on Mandalore they're they're
confronting directly the culture the religion
Etc and I feel like you could unpack that
over the course of this especially as you
know the the more they bring this place back
the more legitimacy the more dispelling of
all the the myths and things like that the
more people are going to be eyeing it and
the more conflicts are going to arise and
the more the sectarian you know debacle that
partly ripped this place apart is going to
come back into The Fray so I feel like you
can get that but at the same time yeah I don't
I don't expect this to just go full and or
and I don't think it should because this should
be a bit of a swashbuckling Adventure um but
yeah this feels like something I love the
way this ended too because this ends in a
very definitive like no we're going to continue
this next time this isn't over by a long shot
and uh that's exciting in and of itself and
and as a bonding experience for these two
very different points on a plane you know
these two poles as DIN and and Bo you know
are sort of forced into the situation together
I think there are a lot of interesting opportunities
for subtext uh you know that can still be
fun I think we're just gonna go to tattooing
and follow Jawas next week let's do it do
a do a bottle episode with just Pele in the
drawers yeah this no this whole this all seems
like it's about them realizing the Grays in
their belief system that you know vocatan's
really was constantly like you are so wrong
about everything and then in jar is like my
Creed is what it's all about and then you
know he shows him he's like oh [__] this
place isn't actually cursed and then she's
seeing his commitment to this baptism and
as she's Rising I don't know why the myth
of soldiers was like you're coming down here
all right you can leave now the myth is our
Beast even her seeing that it's like wait
a minute there must be some truth to these
things I've always called fairy tales yeah
and so what we're gonna see here is I yeah
it sounds like we're headed towards a union
yeah and I'm I'm excited for that but you
know for a union to happen you do need some
type of thing and that's what's so wonderful
about Star Wars as as a whole has always been
so definitively good and evil and I feel like
mandalorians in so many ways represent us
and like the real world and the fact that
like at some point you know you have to like
not to throw out your Enlightenment era philosophy
or anything but like you know uh I may not
agree with a single word you say but I'll
defend to the death you're right to say it
and this idea of like coming together all
of Voltaire and and figuring out how do we
co-exist and recognize that like whatever
we are and that's many facets is more important
to keep together than it is to just have our
individual sentiment yeah uh be kept alive
so it's exciting well I think when um ninjarin's
people are riding the bus they should be in
the back yeah they are not pure mandalorians
and they should be treated as such yeah I
think that's how you do it that way you can
coexist this is the way that is not the way
it is this is the way get on come on dude
we outnumber you so as well so buddy you shouldn't
say to the nice Jewish boy in the corner uh
no it's um we view you like an equals that's
what we're willing to say to you yeah yes
any other nice Jewish boy we would not be
talking to yeah well uh you're different I
am you're one of the good ones one of the
cool Jewish boys Michael how deep can we dig
this um right into the mines
we should wrap this up it's all obviously
also going towards grogu becoming the ultimate
Mandalore sure about time we say that but
will his helmet have ear holes yes well that
is kind of the final if the mandalorians can
get over the differences between each other
grogu represents that ultimate bridging of
the gap between the Jedi and the man you start
it's fresh start yeah until the next Mandalorian
Civil War 20 years later there's too many
mandalorians out of control all these emotions
and corner and integral Corners don't of your
religion I I feel like conflict is insured
well the lack of violence is a sin which does
spread a little bit of chaos so ah well we're
gonna do all righty guys well what did you
think about this episode of the Mandalorian
leave your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe leave a like follow Michael um who
was our Neil deGrasse Tyson of the Star Wars
world right now I think shoes to fill very
big shoes yeah and who do you do you think
anybody is alive and if so who what are they
doing are they okay I'd love to hear your
thoughts I'll respond let's do a pick
Michael since you left to talk can you shout
out pandemic Jones pandemic Jones congratulations
you are the patron of the day thank you for
your support your love and especially your
money uh no we are so grateful you make it
really personal though oh I don't want to
just sound like you know like some general
oh you want to make it personal it's a general
thing pandemic I know you've been going through
a lot lately you know with the government
being like you're over but sure you're not
over to me pandemic pandemic when I go to
sleep at night I often think about I wonder
what Greg's editing right now and I know when
Greg's editing what he's really thinking about
is thank God for him we're pandemic Jones
that that guy is single-handedly keeping this
channel going and I I just want to say from
the bottom of my heart since Greg doesn't
have one anymore no um thank you it's on the
front of us oh my God Jesus Christ no seriously
uh you know it's really easy to forget that
the real rejects uh are real people and you
know Greg is a great guy John is a guy no
yeah and uh and I know that they as human
beings view you as their Eagle which Speaking
from experience is surprising and unusual
for them so I view you higher than me I look
up to you pandemic Jones I'm nothing you did
it I did it do we have to do the letter thing
P for no no please let me know if you're new
and only do Star Wars references when it happens
now P for uh Paz visla ah yes the the big
Mandalorian yeah yeah he was here last week
yeah who ate lots of
I was I was going to go for the pantoines
yes Star Wars I get it they could be the creatures
from this episode whose name now eludes me
and he spelled auxiliary n is for Naboo and
one star okay okay everyone stop stop talking
D is hidden
[Music] laughs